Well we're out there,
ladies and gentleman without a net.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you today by marijuana.
Totally.
Let's be honest,
just start from the beginning.
Let's say that we know we,
we think a lot of things
on this podcast as well.
You know,
have our sponsors.
We thank people like the coconut water
people who are not really a sponsor
where,
who's not really a sponsor.
But God it,
we need to thank marijuana.
Yeah,
we really do.
And fuck naked coconut water.
We,
that stuff is terrible.
I saw you tweet that.
Oh it's so bad.
It's totally different than co two o
two o is delicious and sweet boy people
have had the crappy coconut water.
They always talk shit about coconut water.
Like why do you drink that?
And you're trying to be like
trendy like you have no,
I had no idea.
Okay.
I found out from my friend Edwin,
he came into Jiu Jitsu class and we had,
uh,
it was,
you know,
we do a mostly no gauge Jujitsu,
but every now and then a guys
decide to have like a Brazil night.
So they put like gs on,
I brought coconut water and dude gave
me a coconut water and I was like,
well that was nice and you know,
I was like looking forward to this
fucking watered down elephant load,
sort of a taste,
you know,
it's a terrible taste and instead
it was sweet and delicious.
I was like,
what the fuck kind of
coconut water is this.
That's how I found out about two o like
I kept the can and then went online and
ordered it on Amazon and I was,
and as soon as it got there I was like,
well let's see if this stuff is
just like the stuff that he had.
By the way,
those cans are hardcore.
I bet that like,
like,
like when people go through
trash and I find those,
they're like,
oh fucking jackpot.
I bet there's,
these are worth like $2 or so.
It would be really good if the end of
the world was coming and you wanted to
make some sort of a can raft
seal them all up together.
Totally.
That would work.
Yeah,
that's hardcore.
there is so delicious.
If you've never liked coconut water,
you need to try one of two things.
First of all,
fresh coconut water,
coconut water that's not pasteurized with
the already drilled and has a sticker
over it.
And then just peel the sticker
off and drink right from it.
It's great.
That is the best if you can get that,
that is the best fit.
But C two O is a close fucking second.
And when I'm writing,
like especially when I'm,
I'm,
I'm brainstorming in my office,
I got the little refrigerator
right next to my desk.
I'll drink four or five of those bitches.
I got to get up to pee
like every 40 minutes.
Right?
But they're so good.
It's like it like it,
it,
when you're working out hard and
you drink some coconut water,
it feels like the best thing ever.
It feels,
Gatorade feels pretty
good when you're tired,
you know,
and you,
you work out and like you need something,
something new,
something that's a little
more potent and just water.
Gatorade feels good,
but coconut water feels fucking amazing.
It's so delicious.
And you feel like you're a healthy savage
out there drinking some tropical fruit
juice,
you know Ha.
It's not even choose it's water.
I know.
It's delicious.
Shit.
Super good for you too.
I liked that.
When you have the actual coconut though,
cause then you get to
kind of eat at the inside,
like eat with a spoon.
You know c two o just told me they're
going to send me a new case that has pulp
in it.
So you,
it's like we had those
from Amy and Brian's,
which I like him.
He's like,
yeah,
it's a weird,
it's a weird thing.
You're drinking something and there's
like little chunky chewy things inside of
it,
but I like it.
Yeah,
it's like a goober.
I know.
It's true.
It's coconut.
It's like you're getting
a little chewy coconut.
You're getting a little fiber in the,
you know,
with the,
with the milk.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's,
I like it.
It's a weird thing though.
It's an acquired taste.
It's like all of us ever had chia seeds.
The Chia drink,
like the stuff that makes the pet grow,
the you sprinkle on it,
she as well.
Could you imagine if there like
somehow or another that was a drug?
Well,
you know,
that is the case with a morning glory.
Seeds.
Did you know that morning glory
seeds are like Super Psychedelic?
Apparently some of them are.
Apparently they've done something to
some of the morning glory seeds that they
sell in certain places.
You gotta be careful that they
weren't chemically treated to kill the
psychoactive effect of them apparently.
But if you get like pure
morning glory seeds,
it has a very like LSD type effect to it.
I was pretty fucked up
Brian.
I lose you.
No,
I was just thinking of
how I was going to take,
I bring this into a fleshlight
commercial where we're rolling,
dude.
It doesn't matter to take off this
logo off your face so they can see the
beautiful gyro.
You know,
don't even do that like
that and the darkness.
Um,
thanks to fucking make shit up.
Thanks to on it.com.
Let's go with them first.
Oh,
the fuck.
Why not?
I guess I could have a
boner during this crazy.
Let's close strong with the flashlight,
right.
Uh,
we have at [inaudible] dot com that's
o and n I t just in a battle ropes and
kettle bells is the newest products.
Um,
if you're familiar with
anybody who's ever done like,
um,
uh,
any sort of mixed martial arts training,
have you ever watched like
the UFC countdown shows?
Uh,
two really popular methods of
conditioning our kettle bells and a ropes.
I personally have never used the battle
ropes and I'm looking forward to doing
it.
But I'm a big proponent of kettle bells.
It's essentially the only way
I lift weights these days.
I feel like it,
it,
uh,
it gives me like what what it is.
If you've never seen him before,
it looks like a bowling
ball with a handle on it.
It's a giant ball of lead and you know,
you can get them as light as
10 pounds and you can get him,
you know,
heavy up,
know you get 70 pounders in night.
Some dudes can throw
around like 120 pounders,
like big,
giant,
crazy dudes.
Uh,
really unnecessary though.
If you want to get a great workout,
you can get a great workout
with a 35 pound kettle bell.
It sounds ridiculous,
but there are some,
by the way,
which are sold out now because we've
been talking about them on the podcast.
Yeah,
you can't get that.
Tried buying those videos
that we talked about,
the extreme kettlebell cardio workout
dudes are texting me saying that they're
sold out everywhere now,
so I'm glad because a,
it's a really good product
and I make no money from that.
I just want to let you know,
just letting people know the fuck is good.
I think I just got shocked.
I think you did too.
I saw you move funny thought.
Maybe it was a spider bite and you're
going to turn into a fucking spider man.
I thought this was some
sort of viral marketing.
Jesus Christ.
Isn't there a news places hot?
It's not hot.
Haunted,
man.
We got issues.
Just got shocked.
You're going to be okay,
Sweetie.
Anyway,
on a.com go check it out.
I took my three Alpha brains
right before the show.
What is Alpha Brain Joe?
It is a cognitive enhancing supplement.
What does that mean?
It's called the new tropic.
What they,
ours are essentially nutrients.
They're supposed to increase
your brain's ability to produce,
to produce neurotransmitters.
Now that coming out of my mouth is just
really a bunch of noise because I'm way
too fucking stupid to understand
the science behind any of that.
Thankfully,
there've been some really intelligent
people that have sort of deciphered it.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com there
is a link where you can get to see the
science behind on it and the
science behind nootropics
and I suggested if you're
interested in any sort of vitamin or
supplement or anything that you get to put
into your body,
you should do a little research on it.
I mean,
people don't like to do that,
but I'd just like to take things,
but there's a,
there's a lot of research pro and con
about nootropics and about even vitamins.
I am a very strong believer in
health and nutrition and vitamins.
I'm a really strong believer
in eating really good food,
but I also believe that you
help your body with nutrients.
I've had personal health issues
that I've helped with vitamins.
I know they have a positive
effect on your body.
You know,
I think you have to just be careful
about what you take into your body on a
regular basis.
And if you're interested in any
sort of a nootropic formula,
like whether it's on it,
uh,
Alpha brain or a bill Romanowski stuff,
neuro one that I've talked about before
or any of a number of mixtures that
people put together online.
Um,
just Google it.
Google look into that shit.
If you're interested
in getting Alpha brain,
the first 30 pills when you
buy any of our supplements,
first 30 pills are 100%
money back guarantee.
If you don't like it,
you don't even have to
send back in the product.
You just say,
this isn't for me.
That's how confident we are first of all
in the product and how much we really
want to make sure that nobody feels
like they're getting ripped off.
That's just a fact.
And if you buy it and you don't
like it and then we're done,
it's okay.
It's like everybody's different.
I could not tell you how
your brain functions.
I could not tell you how your body feels.
I know for a fact that there's some
supplements that I enjoy that other people
don't enjoy and some shit
that they used that I don't,
I try it and it doesn't
do anything for me.
Everybody's system is slightly
tweaked in one way or the other.
So we want make,
make sure that no one feels ripped off.
But these are really good products and
their products that I have been involved
with long before I was in a
business relationship with them.
I've always been a fan
of nootropics and uh,
vitamins period.
Go check it out on a.com oh and an ITU.
Codename Brogan.
Save yourself 10% off.
We are also brought to
you by our first and our,
our longest friend and
this podcast venture,
the fleshlight.
I just came already from battle ropes
and I don't even have a covered on for
this flashlight.
Well I how did you come from battle ropes?
Cause I was thinking about him.
Battle ropes making you come girls with
really big boobs swinging those battle
ropes around naked.
Oh,
thank that.
You would,
we worried about that because those girls
maybe could kill you with their hands
and girl could whip those
battle ropes around.
Did you,
do you think light salt
sell toys now for women?
Like really high end vibrators,
like big dicks?
No,
no.
Like,
like really like really
good vibrators now.
Oh really?
Yeah.
For Women.
The new,
like a new product.
A high end versions.
High End.
Yeah.
Like a Mercedes.
Like what is it?
Well not just like a cheap ass,
you know,
crappy rabbit or something like that.
They actually sell it as the,
I'm the best one.
What is the,
I mean is there like a
fleshlight of dildos?
Yeah.
What is it?
Is it the rabbit or something?
Yeah,
you could die over there
if you die over there.
I want you to know I love you.
I want to just,
I'm so selfish of her care.
If he dies,
I just want you to think
good about me before he died.
I don't know what I'm,
um,
maybe we should just wrap up.
I'm scared to touch everything now.
Apparently.
Fleshlight how's Dildos?
Dildos?
Well,
Brian,
we would know he is the expert.
If there's a guy looking for Dildos,
I would say,
do you think Brian knows
who he's talking about?
And I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
he knows that's a
part of Brian's charm.
He knows shit about dildos
that calm and they have a
thing for female toys and uh,
one of them is,
it looks like,
oh Jesus.
Oh,
okay.
They,
I think these are the kinds that the
enjoys or what is that what they're,
see dues would be way happier with
vibrators and dildos and stuff if they
weren't shaped like dicks.
If like the best thing for a
woman's pussy was like something,
you know,
mechanical and boxy looking
and you know what I mean?
Like with a tongue and it
just clamp it on the Clinton.
It just,
mom,
if that was like a real sex toy,
we would be cool with that.
I think what trips guys out as
these giant Monster Phalynx,
you know,
these giant Phallic symbols,
these giant Dildos,
he's fake dicks.
They said Lilo's now that makes sense.
They don't make them Lilo's
they're really high end vibrators.
Like that's what all the girls
then I they know or like,
is that what you're saying?
Flashlights?
Hells yeah,
they sell Lilo's which is the best.
Those are the ones that you know that
like they the alien ware's of alienware's
of dildos.
Wow.
That's really sweet.
That's cool.
Brian,
you are silly bitch.
Silly Bitch.
How dare you.
Um,
anyway,
a fleshlight is,
uh,
been a long time sponsor of the podcast.
Uh,
it's uh,
embarrassing subject for some folks and
it makes me cringe whenever we have a
serious guests on the podcast and I
have to mention that were sponsored by a
rubber pussy,
but it's a good product folks.
All right.
And uh,
it just,
it is what it is and everybody
needs to settle the fuck down.
All right.
Hip Music.
Use a code name,
Rogan and it save yourself 15% off
the number one sex toy for men.
That's right.
Bitches
and just when you thought it was
impossible to do that commercial.
A definitely
experience.
Josh Barnett,
Josh Barnett is one of those old school
savages that will actually try to drive
a 1969 Oldsmobile.
He liked drives that shit.
Like it's a regular car.
Like he actually gets on the highway is
like I'm going to go somewhere and my
1969 automobile,
so his crazy ass drove all the way from
Orange County on the four oh five which
is stopped dead like a
parking lot 90% of the time.
So he dropped.
That's a big exaggeration.
It's not even 50% of the time,
but when it stopped dead,
it's a mother fucker.
It is a motherfucker.
It's hard to wrap your head around
how long it's gonna take you.
Cause if you look,
there's like is your five or six lanes
on each side and some spots at least five
at least five maybe
six lanes on each side.
And when I am talking
about there's no room,
it's just all car for miles.
There's no space in between the cars,
all the cards.
So even if they started at the beginning,
they started the front of the line and
that guy moves ahead and the next guy
moves behind him and
they all pick up speed.
The highway speed.
You're there for a fucking hour,
right?
Because it's just,
just getting these cars to move is insane.
It gives you this sense of futility.
It's like,
you look at it,
you like,
these numbers are impossible.
Is,
is anybody monitoring these numbers?
What happens when they
get completely untenable?
What happens when they're
just unmanageable?
What happens when it's
just so beyond belief?
When there's so many cars,
no one can move anywhere.
Do we?
What do we do then?
We fly.
I'll tell you what we don't do.
We don't drive 1969
Oldsmobiles on the highway.
Like they're real cars.
Silly.
Having so much fun with my card.
I haven't owned a car that I've
enjoyed for a very long time.
Like,
like I now enjoy like,
like flying around in my car.
Yeah.
Well,
when you get used to a nimble
car that can move around.
We were talking about this earlier,
like about how old cars are.
Um,
we were,
I was actually talking about it
with the staff that old cars,
like when you see like a 1969,
like a corvette or something like that,
that's like a work of art made by
a bunch of people in a factory.
You know,
they put that thing together and they
screwed those bolts in place and they made
that thing and it has
like this work of art,
sort of a quality to it
that makes it really cool.
But those things drive like shit.
Those things are ridiculously bad.
They did not balanced right.
They go out corners all fucked up like
old muscle cars or the dopiest fucking
things to drive ever.
The really dangerous for the most part,
unless you've completely
up upgraded their breaks,
you're like,
I was talking to bill burr.
Bill burr has like a 1950 pickup truck.
It's so cool.
It's,
it's sounds awesome.
It's like he opened the hood that you
could climb in there with the engine and
Polish it with a toothbrush.
I mean it's,
it's so big and the whole
thing is just ridiculous.
Get it.
And you,
you can actually think like,
oh,
I could actually work
on this car if I had to.
I,
I worked on my car growing,
my dad made me work on cars growing
up and I actually could see like,
all right,
that's the engine.
That's the,
you know,
the alternator.
That's the club.
Yeah.
Dot.
It does.
I mean that is the thrill about those
kind of cars is that you can go to,
you know,
some are like dealership and buy
like old parts for an old corvette.
Like you can order room,
you know,
I mean you,
you can,
you can go somewhere like I know year one
they make parts for like all old cars.
They make replacement
fenders and make all these,
they started manufacturing shit because
so many people love taking old cars and
redoing them.
And this Josh Barnett
is silly for that shit.
He loves it.
He loves cars.
If you look at his Twitter,
it's like all like death
metal and muscle cars.
Josh Button had to savage,
he's a legit savage.
You look at him,
he's like clearly got some crazy
viking gene thing going on.
You know.
He wants to dominate the world that
drives muscle cars and listen to death
metal.
It's going to be a
fucking awesome podcast.
Brian.
Excited.
It's epic,
but right now he's stuck in traffic so.
So what's up?
This weekend's going to be fun man.
Yeah,
we're going to have great USC and
yeah,
this weekend is a chill son and versus
Anderson Silva to the rematch that that
is,
that's going to be scary.
You should stay an extra day
and do the rehab thing with us.
Uh,
yeah.
Why don't you talk about what you're
doing because I don't know if I will be
able to,
uh,
we're in talks right now
and it might start as like,
no,
it's fine.
It's already,
it's already know we already,
we already announced on that by 90 show.
I didn't mean like completely
teased a little bit.
Okay.
I will look,
I uh,
yeah,
we're going every Sunday we're going
to start podcasting live from Rehab,
which is at the hard rock hotel.
And you should say no ring
penicillin with you to Vegas.
No,
I know.
It should bring,
I think it's dangerous.
I think I have to really like,
like I'm going to fly in
and do it and fly out.
I totally,
you're totally getting ready
to start doing cocaine.
I'm just going to go all in.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful.
It's dangerous,
right?
Yeah.
I was carrying your liver,
but it gets the,
the Djs,
the guy from Jersey shore.
Which one?
No,
the one that always has a
really nice hair that you know,
you don't know what I'm about.
Like even here,
my
dad's Pauly d is the
hair stick straight up?
Is that his name?
He djs,
the whole thing.
I met the situation.
Yeah,
we were in the sky rise.
Very nice guy.
Give me a big hug.
We really friendly.
Not a bad guy at all.
I think it's funny.
He's,
he's trying to,
he's trying to make something out of a,
an opportunity,
you know,
came up,
the kid ran with,
he's got a great personality.
People like him,
you know,
you can make fun of him all day,
but that good,
the kids are making millions of dollars
were shown his ass and he's just
partying.
It's really kind of cute.
He ain't a bad guy,
you know,
he ain't a bad guy at all.
I mean,
I see him on the show and look
followed me around when I was 21.
You think I was away?
Bigger Douche bag and
that guy and bad guy.
Yeah,
it's have to be UFC and then maybe
rehab and then Doug Benson show
power station Sunday night.
Yeah.
He's doing a live podcast
type thing or a predict chaos.
Doug Benson the whole weekend,
they'd better not try to smoke weed
out of Doug Bites show at the palace
casinos.
Right?
Yeah.
You've got to be careful
about that because a lot of
people in Vegas or from old
school Vegas,
if you ever fear and
loathing in Las Vegas,
classic work of my favorite author,
a Hunter Thompson,
and he,
uh,
had that whole thing about,
they were on their way to Barstow
when the drugs began to take hold.
I mean it's fucking great.
But that Vegas of like fear and everything
was illegal and if you got caught
with pot,
you would do life in jail.
Like,
if they pulled you over for pot,
you could do 20 fucking years
and that's not bullshit.
And it's probably a lot of people who did.
Probably a lot of kids who
got high in California,
drove on the way to Vegas and got
arrested and spent years in jail.
I mean it's really scary.
It's scary to stop and think about that.
And the people that are
running a lot of those casinos,
those guys had been,
well I started out in the dunes and 69
and then I moved over to those fucking
old school guys.
They don't fuck around man.
You can't be thinking that you're going
to light up joints and one of those
local casinos,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh No,
you just don't do it.
I mean that's why you just drink heavily
and make really bad decisions and you
don't remember anything
and it stays there.
And it's the palace station.
Yeah.
Power stations know those
are all owned by [inaudible].
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well the same guys.
The same guys,
the FERTITTA brothers.
Oh Shit.
I should say the Fertitta
brothers owned zoo fun zoo phones.
UFC.
Cause that's actually how it works.
But yeah,
they are.
They've got some cash so I could
get good trouble and I'll be safe.
Don't say that.
No,
you might be the exact opposite.
You might be a liability in my dig a
hole for you out there and the fuck I
listen old school,
keep it together.
Keep it together,
right.
Call.
No,
I just don't think they're,
Doug should,
uh,
encourage anybody to spark up.
I didn't even think of that.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm going to have to be in watch this
places we can get away with that.
I'm the most places.
No,
especially with Doug knows that like,
I don't think any of you can't,
you can't smoke a cigarette in a theater.
Okay.
And the same reason why
you can't smoke a joint,
because I don't want you
lighting something on fire.
You're stupid.
Fuck,
I don't trust you.
Who knows who's got like pure in there,
you know,
they're fucking,
they're soda bottle and they spill it and
then someone drops a lighter on it and
we're fuck.
And it was a blazing fire
inside the comedy club.
Oh,
you can guarantee you
that's not going to happen.
No,
you can't.
Anything you shouldn't introduce
fire into a room packed with people,
period.
That's why I don't believe in candles.
So I love these little
things that you've done,
these little pods there.
You got some little little sweet jammies
that Brian has and he's got these
little pods all around the,
uh,
the room where they,
they recharge their little batteries in
there and they have different colors and
they're almost impossible to turn off,
which really frustrates me.
How do you look at them to change color?
I'm just moving them around.
There's no rhyme or
reason and the directions,
the directions are purposely insane.
Like they don't have anything
to do with the product at all.
And I think they just do it to
fuck with you because you're like,
anyone that buys these,
they're just going to trip out anyway.
We got to think who would buy this?
If I was the government,
this is exactly what I would do.
I would take the first like gps tracking
devices that we distribute out there
into the world and a target stoners.
So lava lamps,
I would arm those and
these fucking silly lights,
I would only go after the stoners.
They need some lava lamp technology.
They need to put like LCD
screens inside the lava.
And then so like when
you're watching a lava lamp,
it's just like warp TVs
or something like that.
You know what I mean?
Like what if it was like the liquid
was like a TV screen at a game.
You could have like that technology.
That would be annoying.
That'd be weird.
But you can have it tuned in to anything.
Well,
you know what?
It'd be cool.
It'd be cool for a wall effect.
It would be cool if you
projected it on a wall,
you know?
And then,
you know,
yeah.
Most like rave clubs.
Well they fake it.
They really present project
an actual lava lamp.
They project a video of a lava lamp.
Perhaps it's all video,
you know,
they don't,
they don't actually project
the lava lamp itself.
What exactly?
Have you ever been to that Rehab though?
Have you been to one of those parties?
I don't think so.
Maybe long time ago,
maybe.
The,
um,
those,
those things are fun man.
But you can get Sun burnt and you
get fucking drunk out there and uh,
it got to be careful
they'll fall in and drown.
Yeah.
Just look at this though.
Like I,
you gotta wonder how many people are
paying in that water because it's not,
it's not just one.
Look at this shit though.
This is like spring break.
It's crazy.
And it's just insane.
And Vegas is on another level.
It is on another level of democracy.
People are just tightly wound and Vegas
is the one place where it's okay to make
out with your girlfriend,
you know,
and girls start making out with each
other for the first time and look at that.
See right there.
Right on cue.
Was it a shame?
Well just you going to get a little of
that now and then while these girls are
grinding on each other and grinding
and that's a podcasting here,
I don't think that would be good.
I don't think those are our people.
These.
I think the only way they would work is
if everyone here just branched off and
fucked and got this out of your system.
There's no way you can put on a podcast
with so much slinging Dick and pussy all
over the place as you look how,
who's gonna give a fuck about anything?
We have to say,
you're going to be thinking about,
I can fuck her.
I think she wants to fuck,
and she's like,
I think he's going to fuck me.
Oh my God.
Should I let him fuck me.
And then you're doing shots together.
The next thing you know it,
we're floating the river thing.
Yeah,
you got to fuck.
Get that shit out of your system.
Then come down and listen to US assholes
rant because you're not going to be
interested.
Why would you be interested in what?
Anything that we have to say.
Well,
there's so much pussy everywhere.
That's insane.
If this,
this is what Arabs hate us,
Bro.
Videos like this.
Videos like this get out and they don't
even let chicks where they're fucking
regular dresses.
You have to wear burqas and shit.
You know,
Islamic fundamentalists,
they look at this as this is the
downfall of western civilization.
This is Babylon to them.
You know,
of course it's all ridiculous.
And of course,
you know,
completely hypocritical for the most part.
And the guys,
even the guys that were on the planes
that flew into the twin towers,
those guys were at strip clubs
like a couple of nights before.
But this is,
this is what they point to.
If you want to talk to the
decline of Western civilization,
they point to all this undisciplined life.
What they don't understand is they live
in a place where you have to be strict
and disciplined.
You live in a fucking shitty desert.
You know,
if you live in a terrible,
terrible environment and you know,
and everyone is like really
strict and really harsh and mean,
that's because the environment,
you live in socks,
no one can relax.
So the only people that survive are the
people that are like super hardcore.
If the road ends,
Vegas would be safer than la though,
right?
Because I know,
I know there's no water
or anything really there.
Oh sure.
It was lake mead.
Oh,
there's a big lake there.
I think it's a fake lake though.
I don't know if it's an artificial lake.
I don't think it might have been
built by a dam or something like that.
But it's there.
Right,
and it's awesome and they
have a striped bass in there.
You could go fishing in there.
But yeah,
I think Vegas is probably safer than La.
I don't think they would if
they were attacking America,
they want attack our banking system.
If someone was trying to be a terrorist,
they would try to attack
massive population centers.
Vegas for all its craziness,
doesn't really have that
many people live in there.
It's fairly small town.
It'd be easy to escape.
Well,
just once,
if the shit hits the fan,
the resources are going
to run dry really quick.
You're not going to be
able to bring in any food.
And then it's like,
what are you eating when you eat?
There's nothing there.
And it's going to be like,
it really should be,
which is a desert and not,
I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with living in the desert,
it's just the only way to live in the
desert today and this and this world is
you have to have modern power.
You have to have food,
you have to have supermarkets.
You have to be able to get water that
that has to come to you if you live in the
desert because it was just
you live in the desert,
you're kind of fucked.
There's no food out there.
How are you going to grow food?
You can't eat,
there's no water.
You know what I'm saying?
Unless you're bringing in,
you can't really live in the desert.
So the only way to live in the desert
is with modern means and when the shit
hits the fan,
if you're living in the desert,
those modern means would be useless and
then you've got to get the fuck out of
the desert.
So probably the most,
probably the best places.
Then it would be something like,
you know,
yeah,
not bad,
but the winter is a problem.
Transportation is a real cunt.
You know you're going to ride
horses back and forth everywhere.
That's the only way to get around and
you don't want to go too far on a fucking
horse.
You know you don't want to do that.
You don't want to go too far.
If you have to drag shit,
if the horses have to
drag lumber and stuff,
you're going to be,
you're going to want to be as
self sustaining as possible,
but we'll have dogs and I
will have it slaves and dogs,
they'll be like that.
Say it doesn't get that snow.
You can count on it to be that snowy.
It's ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense.
Like reindeers just tons of chick.
All those Chihuahuas,
they will all be put to use as horses now.
They would be trained,
they trample on each other and we would
hate them if we find out how mean they
really are the deep biting the ones
underneath them as they're trying to pull
your sled.
I was watching old looney tunes this
weekend cause this guy named fast.
Eddie told me that.
He's like,
Hey,
do you remember,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
You know a dude named faceting,
has he tried to take
his dick in your mouth?
No,
not yet.
No.
I don't know if that's,
this is the guy makes
you call them fast Eddie.
Which my name Beth Daddy.
They call me fast at this one.
Fast Eddie or right and it's fast.
Eddie fell sin from the fucking hustler.
It's Paul fucking Newman.
That's who it was.
The guy that originally.
That's fast.
Eddie.
You can't call yourself fast setting.
That's completely,
he's a guy from the comedy store.
Do you know who a Hispanic guy?
No,
but he can't call himself fast.
That if somebody else wants
to call caused himself.
First of all,
you better be able to play pool.
Bitch.
You want to call yourself fast?
I don't think he calls himself.
I think other people can,
but they better stop this one fast.
Eddie fast.
Eddie fell son.
What was I talking about?
Paul Newman.
The Hustler.
Jackie Gleason.
Now that's what you're talking about,
bitch.
I wonder.
I think it was 63,
I don't remember what year it was,
somewhere in 1960s,
early sixties.
But God,
what a movie man.
What a great fucking movie.
And if you're a pool player that's like,
you know that movies like
the holy grail of movies.
This is the holy grail of pool movies
cause it was like a really good dramatic
film and it captured this guy's
obsession to be the best pool player.
Although quite honestly,
Paul Newman really does not
have a very believable stroke.
He needed to stay down on
the ball a little bit more.
His fall through it was
a little ham fisted,
whereas Jackie Gleason had a real stroke.
Jackie Gleason could
actually run a hundred balls,
I believe.
I believe you at least ran 75 balls.
Uh,
he was a real player.
You could tell by the way he
would a pocket balls like he was.
He was,
he grew up on pool tables here.
Andy Griffin died today.
Andy Griffin from the Andy Griffith show.
Yeah.
Oh that sucks.
It does suck.
That's like one of those.
Aw Yeah.
Yeah.
Wouldn't.
Nobody hated that guy is fucking nice guy.
He's already buried that he'd died
today and he's already buried.
Wow.
Because he wanted an immediate burial.
Oh,
he probably didn't want to
be embalmed or something.
Yeah.
Is that possible?
Can you say that you're wanting to bond?
Just put a bunch of craziness.
Is this the universe eats our bodies.
All right.
That's just the way it is.
It's set up.
There's a bunch of shit inside the soil.
The soil is not just dirt.
Soil is alive.
It's alive with minerals.
It's alive with organisms.
Just attention is it?
The 10 people acts as a bunch of shit
in there that would eat your body and
that's what it's supposed to
do and you poison that stuff.
You know,
poisoned your bodies and
then cover them with makeup.
So what?
So people can stare.
Number 10 you're not dead.
Why do you have a dead person
with fucking makeup on?
Lying in a bed with a rosary wrapped
around their frozen frigid hands.
Just bury them.
This is craziness.
Staring at a body doesn't
do anybody any good.
What if we totally missed guests?
Like how old they are,
the planet is and that actually every,
all the dirt is just tons of tons of dead
people from like billions and billions
of years.
And like in the middle there just one
person and that's God and he's just
sitting there like,
I'm like in the middle of nowhere.
Well that's,
you know,
that's kind of funny because
that's what like some,
there's some beaches that
are covered in fish bones.
Like the sand is actually like fish bones,
like,
um,
where they have big die offs.
Like what does that solve the seat?
Yes,
the salt and sea.
Exactly.
There's areas I haven't,
you gone personally,
I don't want to go to that shit.
We talked about doing a podcast.
There are whites,
but we like sobered up.
I've talked to so many
people since then that,
cause now that I know what
it is that talk about it,
like,
oh I went there.
What was it like?
It's,
it's stinks.
I don't know if I recommend it.
It's all right.
It's kind of weird,
but it's,
I mean,
it was a pretty miserable
day and I'm like,
oh,
I don't,
I just sound good.
Well,
yeah.
if you don't know what it is,
there's some fucking
amazing documentary on it.
It was that who?
Who made that?
What is it?
The trial?
Something.
Something in pleasures
of the salt and sea.
Do you remember the
name of the documentary?
Dammit.
I'm going to,
I'm going to have to
look it up because it's,
it's,
it's really a fascinating documentary
and it was a all showing how it used to
be.
It used to be like this amazing
resort town or you're binging it.
No,
I'm googling it to see that.
Google,
that picture,
that Google car,
the guy in a car accident,
one of the,
hey,
I want to tell you something.
No,
man,
when you just before you
change the subject on that,
that binging thing,
I tried googling something
and it banged me.
Oh,
on your laptop.
I wrote Google and I did a Google search
and through some Microsoft fuckery it
became a bing search.
It was not,
I did not do that though.
I did not turn it into a bing search.
It became a bing search.
I was like,
wow.
I don't think I liked that.
I think that's Kinda creepy.
Something.
Even if it's just a,
I mean,
that's,
that's fuckery.
Yeah.
Microsoft's tricky like that,
but that's an immediate fuckery.
I've had this thing for two weeks.
That kind of shit creeps me out.
Yeah.
You know,
let me Google it,
bitch.
Why you so scared you'll,
you'll forget about it though.
You'll be bringing your son
getting pinged all the time.
You won't even realize they don't care.
Fuck was I Google searching dude,
uh,
how to come down from really high.
We'd quickly,
why aren't you telling me to go
that the documentary on the Oh yeah.
Salt and say Jesus.
I see
Jesus.
Okay.
John.
I think it's John Waters.
Okay.
John Waters.
Oh,
he,
he just loves documentaries about this.
Hydration's no,
it's,
it's more of a pl.
That's it.
Plagues and pleasures of the salt and sea.
That's the documentary and the,
it's,
um,
it's really,
uh,
a special documentary.
It's really interesting because this
area in our lifetime went from being this
amazing resort were everybody went
to party to being a complete mess.
Everybody moved out.
It looks like the apocalypse man.
The video is insane.
Like when you look at
what it used to be like,
everybody was like driving around there,
their motorboats and catching fish and
they were all drinking and partying.
It was like some crazy like resort.
We're like Sonny Bono grew up and he was
a part of this big movement to try to
bring it back and then you see what it
became and you realize that that can
happen inside our lifetime
from fucking Sonny Bono.
The Sonny and Cher show
was on when I was a kid.
I remember when Sonny Bono died when
he went skiing into a fucking tray.
I was sad.
Sonny Bono seemed like a nice guy,
and from that era,
from his life till now apocalypse,
the whole thing is just dead fish.
So much dead fish that the sand is bones.
There's a,
there's a,
uh,
a boney,
crunchy sand.
The whole place just stinks of dead death.
They have massive,
massive fish die offs were
like a million fish will die.
Yeah.
And they just,
they flood like the inland areas.
So like all the boats of
rotten fish around them.
I wonder if it's like a
bucket of dead pussies,
you know,
like just like that bad.
Or if it's just like,
you know,
like fishy,
bad,
you know,
death is probably the most
depressing smell ever.
I don't think you could be happy
smelling a million dead fish.
It's like nature's letting you
know there's a terrible thing here.
This is what,
whatever's going on here.
This is terrible.
It's led us a million organisms
to shit out and just stop existing
instantaneously.
That's not good.
Yeah.
But it looks,
it looks like it used to be awesome.
It's,
it's crazy to watch.
It looks like it used to be this bad ass
place and everybody would go to and you
know,
you'd go to get your party on w and in
our lifetime it's become a nightmare.
And in this documentary though,
some dudes sates,
not some dude say it's all hype.
And one guy was in the documentary
that actually eats the fish.
He eats it like Sashimi.
He doesn't even cook it.
It just filets it.
And I was like,
wow.
But maybe as bodies just like
so used to that maybe he's like,
while he's doing that,
he's got three cigarettes in
his mouth at the same time,
he doesn't give a fuck about
some fucking pollution.
Right.
You know,
I mean if you really think about what if
you're a cigarette smoker should be you
be even concerned about pollution.
There's no way it could be possibly
as bad as shit your self inflicting.
Alright,
you're voluntarily pumping
that shit in your system.
Eat some dirty Shashimi
what are you worried about?
I'm thinking I'm done with Sushi
and just don't be getting sick.
That last time really
scared me out away from it.
I think you can really fuck your system
up if you get a parasite and they say
that if you want to be really careful,
you should only eat salt water Sushi.
You should only eat like tuna.
And you've gotta be careful
with freshwater stuff
cause freshwater stuff can
contain parasites.
And,
uh,
yes,
you really should cook a
lot of freshwater fishes.
Yeah.
There's certain fish that have parasites,
like salmon,
have parasites.
You have,
you have to be careful and you can get,
you can get sick,
man.
You can,
you're,
you know,
you could fuck up your digestive tract,
and you can,
it's just not good to have little
fucking parasites inside your body.
Contouring it up.
You've really got to see Ted Mann.
That was a really,
really good fun movie.
And if you're like family guy,
it's just,
it feels good.
It,
I like how you used a lot of
the characters in family guy,
but the actor parts,
you know,
like they're real,
they're real people or
actors in the movie.
So everything just feels comfortable.
It's funny,
there's a lot of drug use
like mushrooms and weed in it.
You know,
when I heard that that movie did good,
I was,
I felt like,
uh,
like a,
a good guy one.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like Seth Macfarlane is,
uh,
I only met him once.
I did a an episode of,
uh,
I think that someone was on fear factor
or something like that on a show.
And I did it on a [inaudible] and then
they made fun of me and American Dad too,
so that was kind of cool.
I want to,
but I haven't tweaked people tweet to
get them on a podcast or something.
I'm sure he's busy as fuck now that it's
movies gigantic now his movie took off,
but,
but he's just a genuinely nice dude.
Like when I met him,
he was like genuine.
Like you can tell when someone's like,
here's a genuine smile,
like a friendly dude.
So it's nice when you know,
you find out he's doing well,
but don't tell fucking Delta of
south park guys hate him now.
I don't know.
They shit on him.
I think it's just,
they're just getting out competitive.
Is that what it is?
I don't know.
I don't think they hate him.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Who knows Matt stone and Trey Parker.
I mean,
especially Trey Parker,
he's such a fucking genius that it's like
you gotta like let them go nutty every
now and then.
On things.
It's just,
it comes with the program like you,
you don't,
you know this,
he's,
he's out there like
for how many years now?
Putting out the edgiest 70 most bad ass
cartoon in the history of the world.
I mean,
family guys.
A nice cartoon.
It's a,
it's a fun show and I do owe you.
All right.
Holy Shit.
That was crazy.
Dude.
You got a short somewhere.
We should shut this thing down.
Oh yeah.
You gotta stop licking the microphone.
You Fuck,
I've shorted everything.
It's from you.
Drool and Bro,
that's what it is.
You want to kill the podcast and
try to figure out what's going on.
Sparked my face.
Did you see the spark,
ladies and gentlemen,
this day seems to be cursed.
Uh,
I'm glad that the podcast started at
least a little late because we would have
been stumbling idiots.
We got ahold of some pot
that is from another planet,
as Joey Diaz would say,
is they shit they gave Kennedy before
they took the top off the convertible.
Wow.
You're right.
Are you going to die?
It's sparked like light just
to the podcast from over there.
You'll be good.
Yeah,
we have a serious shortage
and throw some water on.
It will be fine.
That was a white lightning bolt,
bolt spark.
That's God.
Or Fuck,
you've been,
you've been taught that
God for your whole life.
God is upset.
God's upset with you,
Brian.
All right folks,
we're going to have to
figure out what this is.
So Brian doesn't die and we don't want
Josh Barnett to have a flat tire and then
get electrocuted.
That shit would be ridiculous.
So we're going to figure
out what's going on.
Hopefully,
and we'll be back in
about 10 to 15 minutes.
Is that that probably a accurate,
that was a lightening bolt.
It's got to walk it off auto.
I'm going to walk it off.
10 15 minutes.
We'll see you guys a little bit.
Thank you.
Bye.